you know i suspect most people if they
were going to identify any doctor as a
queer icon they would go
with this one not this one
so i'm on record in a number of places
talking about the fact that peter
capaldi the 12th doctor
is at present and i say that because
this has changed previously
my favorite incarnation of the doctor
but i really want to do a dive into one
of the specific reasons
why that is because this is going to
involve
me talking about how it speaks directly
to my own experience
in a way that doctor who otherwise
largely hasn't
before i get too far into this yes
i am going to be connecting the 12th
doctor
and his arc across series 8 9 and 10
with my experience as a gender fluid
person
this is not me making a claim that the
doctor is gender fluid
well i mean they kind of are because
they change gender but
that's not actually what i'm going to be
focusing on
i'm not trying to make a claim that
other people should read the doctor
as some form of lgbtq plus
however he speaks
to my experience in that area
specifically and i
really have wanted to talk about why
for a long time now
gender fluid is well i certainly
consider it to be
some folks are contentious about this
but it is part of the
trans umbrella because transgender is
meant to be an umbrella term
and it refers to anyone who is not
cisgender cisgender being someone who
identifies as the gender they were
assigned at birth i.e
the vast majority of the population now
for people who do not identify as the
gender they were assigned at birth
the one most people are familiar with
would be what i would call binary
transgender people so that's trans men
and trans women people who were assigned
one gender at birth and then
fully transition to living as
the other gender but that does kind of
view gender as a binary
and there are lots of people who fall
under the transgender
umbrella because they don't identify as
what they were assigned at birth
but who don't just swap to the other
gender
out of those two options because there
are far more than two options
there are non-binary people who fall
somewhere in the middle there are
agender people who just
kind of aren't on the spectrum at all
and there's gender fluid people
like me whose position on that spectrum
just doesn't really stay put
at all and
there is an easy way to connect the
doctor
in general to a trans experience
by way of regeneration that's
not how i'm gonna connect though for a
number of reasons firstly as a gender
fluid person my
trans experience doesn't match the
template that
a lot of people think of in terms of
well i was this but i realized i'm this
and so now i'm going to live like that
my own journey has been
very gradual it has been a slow
evolution slow discovery and a slow
change
of my understanding of who i am i've
talked about this on my other channel
that's probably a good primer video to
get a general sense
of how i approach myself
and my own evolution but
that arc that slow
gradual change for me
and from my understanding of myself is a
big part of why i latch on to capaldi's
doctor
because i would argue that the 12th
doctor
is really the only one with a truly
clear character arc
most of the other doctors change a
little
over the course of their time they may
soften a little if they started out a
bit rough
first doctor kind of did that and if you
listen to big finish
the sixth doctor did as well they can
open up and they can become more
personable as opposed to more closed off
eccleston's ninth doctor did that but
that's
not quite the same as an arc it's a bit
of an arc because it's a
change it's them becoming more
comfortable with who they're around and
opening up to them but that's really
just revealing more of who they are
the fundamental cores of who they are
aren't really changing
they're just revealing more of it to the
people around them
capaldi's doctor goes through clear
changes in terms of his understanding of
who he is and how it is
best for him to exemplify that
over those three series i've seen people
criticize his time as being inconsistent
because the way that he behaves in
series eight
is not the same way he behaves in series
nine it's not the same way he behaves in
series ten
now if you don't view it as an
arc yes that can seem inconsistent and
it can be a little bit jarring that it
kind of
seems to jump in between series but for
me it makes 100
sense series 8
he spends the entire time asking
questions like
am i a good man he doesn't know who he
is
he knows something isn't quite clicking
he knows some basics he knows some
fundamentals he knows what he
wants to fight for but as a
person he isn't really sure
of who he is or who he's supposed to be
and by the end he's found something to
latch on to
with that speech that he gives to missy
in death in heaven i am
an idiot passing through helping out
learning and then in series nine he's
embraced that
very fully he has really leaned into the
idea that he's just
he's just an idiot passing through and
trying to help possibly leaned into it
a bit too hard with the sunglasses with
the guitar
with the more casual look with the
hoodies and you could think of that
as god they really just wrote him like
garbage like no
as someone who's had to go through
periods of self-discovery
one of the very common things when
you reach a point where you go okay i
think this is where i'm at
is to dive into it maybe a little harder
than you needed to
sometimes you need to over correct
and then pedal back and actually find
the middle ground where you're supposed
to be
and to me that's what his journey from
series 8
grumpy to series 9 flamboyant
to series 10 where it feels like he has
found
the balance of everything where it feels
like he still
can be fun and silly
yet has not lost that sense of gravity
and he does not let that sense of fun
cause a dangerous situation
that speaks to me a lot
because i can look back to my earlier
days
before i really thought to identify
myself as gender fluid
i would identify as a cross dresser for
a very long time
and back then when i would get into a
feminine mode i would have to go all out
i would have to body shave wig full
makeup
short skirts high heels i needed
all of that to feel like i was
connecting with my femininity
i was overdoing it i found something
that like yes this is definitely a part
of who i am
but i couldn't just explore i dove
headlong into it like the doctor
dove headlong into being the idiot with
a box and a screwdriver in series nine
and then over time as i got more
comfortable
with myself i was able to feel
myself even in a feminine mindset
with a few small touches not
needing every expectation there was a
point when i did need it
but then over time no i don't need all
this
i can find a better balance for myself
and here's the big thing that journey
for me
took time and this doctor's journey
takes time
that means so much to me because i feel
like so often
character arcs for shows like this
can feel rushed or minimal like i said
the way
that i can perceive an arc in most of
the other doctors especially in the
modern era
is basically them either opening up a
little bit more about themselves or
finding the ability to reconnect with
people again after something rough
happened that kind of applies to smith
for instance but that to me
is really only an arc in terms of how
they relate to other people
it's not an arc about how they think
about themselves
and the one other time that i would say
that kind of happens is with tenant and
with things like waters of mars and time
lord victorious which i know has now
become a whole spin-off thing which i
haven't gotten into so
maybe it's better explored there but
sticking to the show yeah no that kind
of just happens quickly and then it's
done
it's rushed but to watch
capaldi over time
question who he is grapple with what
that means
overdo it and then
dial it back and find the happy medium
and to be so assured of who he was
that he was scared to change again
at the end of the doctor falls leading
into
twice upon a time he says
i don't want to change again
never again i can't keep on being
somebody else
and my reading of that part of it is he
has fought
so hard and so long and gone through so
much
to become who he is now the idea that he
might lose that
in an instant is
far more terrifying than the idea that
he might have just
died if he died he would have died as
the person he had fought
and worked and suffered
in order to become and because he
doesn't know what will happen with
regeneration
all of that could change and maybe when
he regenerates
he'll be comfortable in whatever new
identity and sense of self that he has
or maybe maybe the doctor will end up
right back at square one and have to go
through this whole journey again
after everything that he went through
and that is terrifying
the idea of your journey of
self-exploration
of your understanding of yourself
getting undone
is terrifying and i feel like he
captures that fear
and i feel like he earned it by allowing
the audience in to watch him understand
with key moments like the end
of death in heaven like the girl
who died when he realizes why he has
this face
and it is to help him stay the course
and become
the best most true version of himself
that he can
to that declaration and the doctor falls
about
who he is and his refusal to be anything
else
other than that you know maybe there's
no point in any of this
at all but it's the best i can do so i'm
gonna do it and i will stand here
doing it till it kills me you're going
to die too that
journey watching him
not just change from his experience but
change because he is
questioning and looking at and carefully
examining
himself and trying to better know
himself
not for the sake of other people but
because he needs to sort his own
life
that speaks to me so deeply
and it's why i said at the start
i won't rule out the possibility that
another doctor might become my favorite
at some point
but i will be very surprised
i have loved so many incarnations of the
doctor
classic and modern
but i don't have any other
that speaks to my life
my journey it feels like it captures
my struggles and my
fears the way
that peter capaldi's 12th doctor does
and for me
the arc of his character
probably unintentionally but
serves as a beautiful
allegory for lgbtq plus self-discovery
at least in regards to how my journey
went i don't know how many folks have
much interest in this take
but i needed to share it because it's so
core
to what i love about him
what is it about your favorite doctor
that helps you
really connect with them whatever it is
or whatever your thoughts are on
anything i've just said politely leave
your comments down below
and let's talk about it i have a patreon
that is what keeps this entire thing up
and running and there are rewards
for every tier of support there's also
youtube memberships now
with some different rewards if you'd
rather go that way but if you're not
able to
like share subscribe the usual youtube
stuff helps me out as well but
don't even feel too much pressure about
that the thing that i really want you to
remember
is that you are beautiful you are valid
you are loved you are the council
and i only run the meetings and until
next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]